c'est un pays qui a beaucoup de
bienfaits donc il verrait chanter une
certes mais il a des propriétés pour le
coeur il est d'appliquer
cardiovasculaires ils aident à la
digestion ki-moon pu faire ou darjeeling
le thé noir sabine bataillait en connaît
tous ces bienfaits responsable d'une
boutique spécialisée à plaisir elle
anime un atelier de dégustation une
activité proposée dans le cadre de
l'opération good yvelines pour apprendre
les vertus et propriété de cette boisson
on a des thés blancs qui sont très doux
on a des tevere qui ont des préférés
étaient très tournée vers le bien-être
la détente on a des thés semi fermenté
qui ont une complexité aromatique qui
sont assez peu connue type le aux
longues on a été fait mais qui sont
idéaux pour un repas on a des thés comme
leclerc sont des tessons breton était de
garde qui ont des vertus qui sont même
entrés dans la pharmacopée chinoise et
qui ont plein de bonnes vertus c'est
complexe c'est difficile d'affreux quand
quelqu'un vous entendu c'était là et
vous expliquez vous les fait goûter
c'est plus simple température qualité de
l'eau temps d'infusion plus qu'une
culture en quatre mille ans la
consommation du thé est devenu un art en
france deux personnes sur trois on
consommerait et pour les amateurs le
bonté est à étudier de la même manière
que le bon vin comme beaucoup je pense
que je prends le même t tous les jours
et que je voulais m'ouvrir à d'autres à
d'autres sensations à d'autres à
d'autres goûts j'ai eu l'impression de
faire une dégustation comme une
dégustation de vins où justement on nous
fait passer les différents degrés du vin
voilà voilà les différentes années voilà
good yvelines se poursuit jusqu'au 27
novembre avec plusieurs rendez vous
gastronomique le programme est à
retrouver sur internet préparez vos
papilles